all right I want to play a quick this
Quick Clip it's rather disturbing but uh
Prince Harry so he's got his Memoir out
and we talked about Prince Harry a
little bit just to start the week
um and we mentioned how he very much
wants his privacy or claims that he does
and yet he's he he did three quote
unquote major interviews just this week
he's all over the place now he's got
this Memoir out
and even though he's someone who claims
he wants privacy in his Memoir he's not
only airing Dirty Laundry about his
family but he goes into
uh very intimate detail about himself
and and providing information that
nobody asked for
and so I said that there was there's one
part apparently in the Memoir where he
talks about frostbite
um that he suffered on his genitalia
which is already too much information
already TMI
but then this was making the rounds of
social media yesterday there's here's
the audiobook clip of that little
Passage
and it's
way more disturbing than I even
anticipated
um listen
my penis was oscillating between
extremely sensitive and borderline
traumatized
the last place I wanted to be was Frost
nipple Stan
I've been trying some home remedies
including one recommended by a friend
she urged me to apply Elizabeth Arden
cream
my mom used that on her lips you want me
to put that on my todger It Works Harry
trust me
I found a tube and the minute I opened
it the smell transported me through time
I thought as if my mother was right
there in the room
and I took a smidge and applied it down
there
um
so so I was reminding you of your
I don't know we don't want to break that
down I don't want to break that down
anymore than what we already heard there
and except to say that
yeah it's just like it it's an
interesting clip because it starts
it starts disturbing okay we're
beginning at the at the beginning of
this little 30 second clip we hear about
his his penis being traumatized
um which is already too much but then
like as it continues it's just layers
and layers it's this it's this it's like
the a very creepy onion and as you peel
back the layers it just gets worse and
worse and by the end you're you're left
with many more questions
then you have answers and they're
questions that you never really wanted
to ask to begin with
except to say you know maybe the
ultimate answer here is that this is
actually very disturbed this is like a
disturbed person uh Prince Harry is and
I also don't I don't understand why we
still call them Prince Harry maybe
because nobody know what's his last name
so it's just just saying Harry sounds
weird so that's the reason he still has
the prince thing going on
but it is a very disturbed person and uh
he's somebody with
mommy issues and uh and daddy issues and
all kinds of issues the new year will
bring new problems as the left continues
their vicious attack on religion and
morality but you and I can continue to
fight the good fight by remaining rooted
in our faith the best way to do that is
with hallow hallow the number one Prayer
app in the world has everything I need
to maintain a daily prayer routine it's
got over 6 000 audio guided prayers
meditations and peaceful music playlists
plus daily reminders we'll encourage you
to keep up with your team start the new
year with daily Bible readings and
Reflections from the number one
Christian podcast the Bible in a year or
pray alongside Mark Wahlberg Jim
Caviezel Jonathan Rooney
um just like physical exercise daily
spiritual exercise is critical to your
well-being especially in a world where
attacks on faith and religion are
happening all around us every day try
hallow for three months free at
hello.com Matt Walsh that's hello.com
Matt Walsh
they might also explain
how he ended up with
Meghan Markle in the first place
we talked about this on Monday I said
that Meghan Markle is like the perfect
she's really the perfect model
for men to look at uh so that they can
like look at her and everything about
her and the way that she is and
especially the way that she uh conducts
herself in a marriage as a wife and then
look at that and then find the opposite
of that just find the opposite of
everything about her and you'll be doing
okay because all the red flags are there
one of the major red flags for me for uh
Meghan Markle is that she has no respect
for for Harry's family she hates his
family has no respect
there's another viral clip and I was
looking for and I couldn't find it I
didn't spend that much time looking for
it but there's another clip that was in
there in their Netflix mini series that
uh that came out as part of their quest
for privacy and that came out back in
December
and there's a Now sort of Infamous clip
where she is um making fun of uh uh
Queen Elizabeth and making fun of like
making a joke about the first time that
she met Queen Elizabeth and just just
like in this very mocking kind of eye
rolling way and meanwhile Prince Harry
is sitting there and you could tell he's
not comfortable with having his family
made fun of this way especially in
public on camera but he's just sitting
there like a you know a little tame
puppy dog
and so I said
one of the red flags you're looking for
as a man when you're trying to find a
wife
is uh if you find a woman and she
doesn't respect your family she hates
her family she wants to isolate you from
your family and from your friends and
people closest to you that's a red flag
uh the question for for Harry is like
did she did he not know this about her
and more and more I'm starting to think
well he did know this about her and
that's one of the reasons that he
married her
for him the red flag was What attracted
him
because of all his family issues and the
fact that that she resents his family is
part of the reason he married her it was
meant to be you know uh a finger in the
eye of of his family and all the rest of
it
that's the psychoanalysis but I'll
leave most of that for someone else
that'll do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block you can become a member today and
you use code Walsh at checkout for two
months free on all annual plans hope to
see you over there if not talk to you
tomorrow or rather talk to you next week
but we have two more kids
um Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]